hi welcome back to me my summer hiatus
is over and the monitor is back in full
effect and with the summer behind us we
have a fall that is full of outrageous
fantastic why did I use those two words
pop culture releases so this week we are
going to welcome the new television
season with open arms talking about one
of my favorite shows that is back all
over again we are also going to talk
about one of my favorite video games
from last year that is now available in
an all new format but first we're going
to talk about me getting a late pass for
one is clearly one of the best comic
books to come out this year and that
book is fatale written by Ed Brubaker
with art by Shaun Phillips they are a
team who was done fantastic noir and
crime stuff in the past sleeper
incognito criminal etc but fatale
started in January I didn't really
notice I mean I kind of noticed but I
didn't read it and then I didn't read it
and then I didn't read it and then while
I was gone from the monitor I finally
caught up on the series and good Lord
people this is one of the best written
comics I have read in a very very long
time it is a crime with a healthy dose
of supernatural and some horror in there
it is the tale of it's kind of a 2 times
a 2 generation thing it is a guy in the
present trying to solve a mystery of
what happened to his father's best
friend and also by extension his father
there is also a mysterious enticing
woman who appears in both timelines the
present day and also back in the 50s and
there is also a criminal underworld with
some very demonic tones and it is just
gripping it is so well put together as
is par for the course for these two and
it is well worth your time there only
seven episodes in eighth is about to
come out i believe so you have plenty of
time to sit down this week and just
gobble it all up in one go should you
have the money to indulge your tastes
that way it's comic book they're like
two bucks a pop now so do that yes by
all means fully endorsed that is the
cosine from the monitor but now let's
talk about the new TV
season and God am I excited for that
okay thank you for that we can we talk
about television for a second one of my
favorite things in the universe in
particular the new fall season now the
Breaking Bad is over what is next you
know what's next starting Tuesday sons
of anarchy that's what's next one of my
favorite shows on television hands down
is back detail of the Sons of Anarchy
motorcycle club from Northern California
or as some of us like to call them
SAMCRO Sons of Anarchy motorcycle club
redwood originals what the club which
you may know we may not know is
embroiled in some things that have been
happening over the past few years and
some very very specific personnel
changes happened at the end of last year
bit of a cliffhanger what happened
what's going to happen you know what
happens new people are coming around
there's some new blood on the scene in
SAMCRO land in charming California where
the sons are based specifically Jimmy
Smits is around this year and if you saw
Jimmy Smith season of dexter a few years
ago you know that he's capable of giving
some fresh energy to a good show and
considering that I'm of the opinion the
son of anarchy is a way better show than
dexter is especially especially as of
late you'll understand perhaps why I'm
so excited for this year so get your
season pass an order because you know I
have mine and in such a celebration of
that and in preparation for the season
premiere on Tuesday I'm gonna go in here
get a drink and try not to get my ass
kicked back to you okay thank you for
that hope you get out unscathed I'm sure
you will you are a resourceful chap
let's talk about video games q3 and q4
are coming and the release calendar is
about to get nuts but first one of my
favorite games from last year which was
a downloadable title called bastion we
loved it here at Wired actually put it
on our top 10 list of 2011 but last week
supergiant the developer of Bastion
brought it out for the ipad and
surprisingly it is as fun in a touch
screen format as it was originally what
they actually did was they streamlined
it a bit so that combat is a bit more
automatic all you have to do is worry
about defending and evading rather than
actually swinging your axe or firing
your guns or whatever it is if you are
not familiar with Bastion it is a kind
of almost fully top-down kind of hack
and slash RPG with a narrator who is
grizzled old coot who's basically
telling the tale of your journey and
they they recorded thousands of lines of
of narration so it seems to be
pertaining almost exactly to the things
you're doing and if things that are
happening to you which if you have not
played it before the first time you
played it is it is an absolute
mind-blowing experience I try to let the
kit down gently this is the bastion all
right said no one else showed up really
well done on with headphones for the
ipad in fact they recommend that and I
would as well but it's only 499 for
hours of gameplay it's the exact same
game as the downloadable from last year
it also just became available in the OS
10 for regular max in the App Store but
for five dollars with it with a really
nice streamlined touchscreen control
scheme well worth it and it was kind of
a big surprise for a lot of us that that
supergiant did this port but it is
really really well done really well
polished and I'm having fun with it all
over again even if you enjoy Bastion
last year I I beseech you I beseech you
to give it a try for iOS because it is
that well done a port but that's it for
this week on the monitor we will be back
because summer vacation is over we will
be back next week in the meantime email
us at the monitor and wired com with
suggestions criticisms solicitations and
love and until then inspirational
catchphrase here
you